qué medidas se os dijera que vivir en
una casa de 25 metros cuadrados os sale
más caro que vivir en una vivienda de
mira está el edificio rojo de la
diapositiva
ese edificio está en el barrio de
lavapiés en madrid
y la semana pasada pasaba yo por ahí y
me fijé en un pequeño detalle en junto a
la entrada y era el telefonillo en los
botones y la gran cantidad de botones
que tenía para lo aparentemente pequeño
que el edificio y me pregunté cuántas
viviendas tiene este pequeño edificio
dentro qué es lo que hay
cuando llegué a mi casa después me puse
a revisarlo y entré en el catastro que
tiene los datos públicos aunque tú
puedes ver las viviendas que que
componen cada cada finca y vi que dentro
de ese edificio en una parcela de unos
250 metros cuadrados había 22 viviendas
un local comercial además de el patio y
una pequeña corral a detrás y en total
son como unos 650 metros en total todo
el edificio construidos
y además pensando un poco también en la
composición sociodemográfica que tiene
el barrio de lavapiés y concretamente
esas calles con mucha población de
origen inmigrante y también pensando en
la ocupación que hay media en cada
vivienda pues pensé que quizás haciendo
una estimación a lo mejor podría haber
unas 40 personas viviendo dentro de ese
edificio
pero además pensando todavía un poco más
dije y conociendo el problema que tiene
madrid con los precios en los alquileres
y la vivienda vamos a ver un poco más a
ver qué es lo que es lo que encontramos
así que accedí a un conocido portal
inmobiliario a ver qué es lo que podía
encontrar
y resulta que los últimos diez años ha
habido publicados hasta 30 anuncios de
alquileres en ese edificio y en total de
media entre todos ellos han sido unos
630 euros mensuales que si hacemos un
cálculo podemos fácilmente deducir que
por esas 22 viviendas se están generando
casi 14 mil euros al mes estarían
generando el caso y casi 14 mil euros al
mes y además pensé pensad que esas
viviendas no llegan más allá de los 30
metros la mayor parte de ellas tiene
entre 2030 alguna hay una de 80 incluso
una de 19
y para hacer un punto de comparación en
ese mismo portal inmobiliario dije vamos
a ver una vivienda que tenga todo este
tamaño equivalente de unos 650 metros lo
más cercano posible de ese lugar pero
que sea una única vivienda
y nos encontramos con esta otra esta es
la calle josé ortega y gasset en el
barrio de salamanca o son 659 metros
cuadrados y por ello nos están pidiendo
ocho mil quinientos euros al mes es
decir que
el metro cuadrado en el barrio de el
metro 4 en esta segunda vivienda en el
distrito de salamanca nos estaría
generando unos dos euros con 90 cada mes
y en cambio en el barrio de lavapiés el
metro cuadrado nos está generando en
torno unos 21 22 euros y aquí llega la
pregunta qué está pasando aquí cómo es
posible que un lugar como el barrio de
salamanca que tiene un precio tanto del
suelo como las viviendas bastante
superior al que tiene en lavapiés genere
realmente menos proporcionalmente pues
lo que tenemos aquí
lo podemos llamar como quizás el negocio
de las mini viviendas o incluso las
infraviviendas y cómo funciona este
negocio bueno pues está directamente
afectado por el precio de vivienda
resulta que el precio la vivienda
frecuentemente se haya afectado por un
montón de condicionantes como puede ser
el tamaño las características la
ubicación un montón de diversas
características que entran todas a
formar ese precio pero es que a
diferencia de lo que sucede con otros
mercados es que también le afecta en
como estos factores se relacionan entre
ellos de modo que
una persona podría pensar y bien pensado
decir una vivienda más pequeña me sale
más barata porque tiene menos metros y
una vivienda más grande pues me sale más
cara lo cual es parcialmente cierto pero
no del todo porque es que resulta que
cuando vamos a una vivienda más pequeña
también afecta la demanda que hay sobre
ella las características de la renta de
las familias en españa nos dicen que la
mayor demanda de viviendas va a ser
precisamente en estas más pequeñas
porque son las que van a poder asumir
entonces fácilmente tenemos que las
viviendas que tienden a ser más pequeñas
también por la demanda que tienen al
revés tienden a aumentar su precio pero
en el caso contrario en la vivienda y lo
en el barrio salamanca en este caso
sucede lo mismo sucede lo mismo pero al
revés al tener más metros la vivienda
sale más cara pero la demanda que hay
sobre ella es mucho menor por lo tanto
tiende a abaratarse por este motivo así
que nos encontramos con un mercado en
las que proporcionalmente las viviendas
pequeñas son más caras y las más grandes
son más baratas
pero es que esta circunstancia además
afecta directamente a las personas que
pueden optar estas viviendas porque la
persona que opta a una vivienda más
pequeña o la familia toda la vivienda
pequeña por esta circunstancia tendrá
necesariamente que destinar mayor parte
de su esfuerzo económico a financiar la
más que lo que tendrá que hacer una
familia en el caso de la vivienda de
josé ortega y gasset llegado a este
punto y muchos se habrán planteado de
los que están aquí que se puede hacer
con todo esto
pues quizás habría que abordarlo por dos
vertientes
quizás una considerando el precio de la
vivienda y otra considerando las propias
características si nos ponemos primero
con las características
puede que todos podemos llegar a un
consenso y generalmente en los colegios
arquitectos hay un cierto consenso en
que una vivienda para que se considere
digna o vamos a decir mejor adecuada o
habitable tienen que reunir una serie de
requisitos como pueden ser un tamaño
adecuado y servicios ventilación luz
la onu en su programa hábitat nos dijo
que a partir de la declaración de los
derechos humanos en 1948 que la vivienda
es un derecho fundamental la vivienda
adecuada además matiza y nos dice que
tiene que reunir una serie de
características aunque tampoco matiza
exactamente cuáles son concretamente
también nos lo dice en el pacto
internacional de los derechos económicos
sociales y culturales del 66
y podemos pensar que una vivienda tal y
como la consideramos todos puede que
vaya más podemos decir que sea en torno
a los 60 metros puede ser una vivienda y
menos de 60 metros ya podríamos está
hablando de mini vivienda que para
muchos colegios de arquitectos esta mini
vivienda se debería destinar
exclusivamente a un uso temporal puntual
o pasajero no es un espacio el que tú
puedas desarrollar una vida una vida
entera
el tamaño de las viviendas aunque hemos
oído hablar mucho de casas colmenas que
se han implantado en otros países como
en hong kong singapur incluso en
barcelona ha habido algún intento aunque
hay dudas sobre la legalidad el tamaño
de las viviendas en españa tiene una
regulación una cierta regulación aunque
es diferente en cada comunidad autónoma
están las cédulas de habitabilidad que
en algunas no existen otras y que
establece unos criterios mínimos que
tienen que tener una estancia para que
sea habitable y en las que no existe
está figura están las licencias de la
primera ocupación que garantizan que
cumple la legalidad vigente para que
pueda ser habitado esto dado que por
ejemplo en madrid para que hagamos una
comparación directa con las viviendas
del edificio que estábamos viendo una
vivienda mínimo tiene que tener 38
metros cuadrados y tiene una habitación
o 25 si es solamente una estancia y para
que os hagáis una idea si revisamos el
catastro en ese edificio nueve viviendas
en edificio rojo nueve viviendas estaban
por debajo de esos veinticinco metros
quizás debiéramos plantearnos cómo
evaluamos esto qué es lo que
consideramos vivienda o cómo permitimos
quizás que exista este tipo de
circunstancia pero es que además no
solamente tenemos que considerar el
tamaño porque al final
el tamaño de esta vivienda es
consecuencia directa del precio que
tiene de la capacidad económica de la
gente que adoptará ellas y con el precio
sucede algo quizás incluso más
complicado de hecho actualmente y muchos
habéis escuchado se debate sobre si se
puede regular si hay que limitar precios
si hay que poner más oferta para que el
mercado se reduce para que se reduzca el
precio del mercado digamos que hay una
discusión abierta en la sociedad sobre
ello pero aquí al final quizás y es el
punto que además os quiero poner
quizás debamos hacer todo es una pequeña
reflexión sobre cómo consideramos
nosotros la vivienda yo creo que todos
podemos estar de acuerdo en que la
vivienda es un derecho fundamental y yo
creo que nadie duda de eso pero también
es verdad que aunque creamos en ello
también nosotros la utilizamos como un
activo de mercado es decir
en españa una de los principales ejes
aspiracionales y creo coincidiréis
conmigo es el horizonte de comprarse una
casa todo el mundo que tenga vivienda lo
cual es completamente lógico pero poneos
en el punto de pensar que en español
compramos vivienda sí como un lugar para
vivir pero también siempre tenemos esa
doble esta doble ese doble pensamiento
de decir me compro una vivienda pero
siempre quiero tener la certeza de que
si algún día tengo que venderla lo haré
al menos al mismo precio que he pagado
por ella o si no más entonces entramos
en una directamente una especulación
entiendo como positiva o negativa pero
con una especulación
quizás el punto que tengamos que asumir
es que si la vivienda es un derecho
fundamental a lo mejor tengamos que
pensar que como tal ese bien no deba
entrar en ese mercado sino que tengamos
que asumir que se tiene o que se debiera
depreciar el asumir que estamos
utilizando un elemento que es un derecho
pero que si asumimos si asumiéramos que
ese elemento se depreció con el tiempo
quizás esté fuera el punto de partida
para que todas estas circunstancias se
autorregularan en el mercado
inmobiliario
no sé cómo lo veis pero yo os invito a
una reflexión sobre si la vivienda es
compatible entre mercado y si es
compatible ese mercado con un derecho
fundamental como el que acabamos de
contemplar gracias
[Aplausos]